Ah, want to hear something insane? I'm
launching my next book, $100 million
Money Models. And it'll show you how to
get more customers to spend more money
with you in less time over and over
again. And this isn't a small deal. It's
a huge deal. And the event is August
16th and you can register absolutely
free. And last time we did this, we had
hundreds of thousands of people there
live and we nearly broke the internet.
For those of you who are curious what my
next book is, it's already done.
This launch is going to be even bigger.
I'm spending millions of dollars on the
launch itself and you can register for
free and you can also pre-order a copy
and get four amazing bonuses. And I'm
going to give away one secret thing that
I can't tell you what it is yet. What I
can tell you is that it's more than an
NFT. It's less than a Bitcoin, but you
got to be there live.
It's August 16th. Register for free and
I'll see you there.